Judiciary Committee chairman Jim Jordan
sir how are
you fine Sean good to be with you well
one question I got to ask and I probably
been this thing has been pinging what
about Jordan what about Jordan what
about Jim Jordan for speaker would you
consider it Sean we got we got to come
to a decision as a conference we got a
week to do so it's important we do that
and it's important we do that because of
what you had in your monologue any
differences that exist in the Republican
conference pale pale in comparison to
the radical left that now runs the other
party and where they want to take the
country so we had better do exactly what
you said Come Together exactly what
speaker gri said come together and focus
on the things we told the American
people we were going to do and frankly I
thought we were doing that we had passed
the bills we told them we were going to
pass we were doing the oversight we were
we told them we were going to do and we
were stopping the crazy Omnibus that
inevitably gets sent to US every year
right before Christmas we were focusing
on the appropriation process like we're
like we're supposed to do I I thought
that was happening and frankly I thought
what happened to Speaker McCarthy was
not fair okay next question would you
have people been coming to you asking
you if you'd consider being speaker and
would you consider
it look I'm going to leave that to the
conference of course I've talked to
colleagues or colleagues have come to me
and talked to me about that but this is
a decision for the conference where and
I don't think it I don't think a great
guy he's given on your behalf and I'm
like I can't speak for my friend Jim
Jordan uh so you can I take that is a
you would be open to
it I think it's a conference decision I
think Steve would also be a great
speaker I think Steve has given so much
for our country uh he's done an
outstanding job as majority leader but I
do think the conference going have to
get together and decide we go from
tonight no I think this is this is a
conference
decision conference comes to you we got
a four seat
majority if the conference comes to says
we'd like you to be the speaker would
you do
it I'm going to talk to the conference
over the next week Sean I think that's
the key I don't I think this is a day
where we say look what happened here was
not good I think what happened to Kevin
McCarthy was not fair let's figure out
how we come together as a conference and
focus on our agenda focus on the three
things this that this Congress I think
is about and we've passed many of the
bills we told the country we would do we
need to stay focused on that pressured
the Senate to actually bring them up for
goodness sake continue to do the
oversight and then obviously deal with
this appropriation process and the
spending bill that has to be done before
the end of the year I'll offer you some
unsolicited advice if they do come to
you and they do offer it to you and you
will consider it uh this idea of one
person motion to vacate I wouldn't take
it with that provision that has to go I
don't think that's good for anybody uh
my humble opinion all right let's move
on to you know how quickly can
Republicans you know fill this position
and move forward with their agenda we
have four of the 12 Appropriations bills
done uh it we have a CR that we didn't
want I thought again chip Roy Byron
Donald Scott Perry Freedom caucus guys
put forward a plan that would have been
a lot better that would have put the
pressure where it belongs on Senate
Republicans and they need to have the
pressure put on them um and then
resolved in conference that would have
been a much better way to handle it and
it would have bought time to get the
Appropriations bills finished with those
Appropriations bills finished do you
believe Republicans can go back to
regular order get those bills done cut
spending secure the border and take care
of the top priorities that should be
Republican priorities I I do Sean we can
pass all that but if the Senate doesn't
do anything you're you're inevitably
going to be in this this stalemate
situation this star down situation where
at some point you got to pass something
and what I hope we would be willing to
do is focus on the issue that's front
and center right now in the country this
is what was in the bills that
unfortunately we couldn't get the votes
for last week the issue that everyone
knows is front and center is the Border
Republicans get it Independents get it
more importantly Democrats get it if we'
have put that on the stop Gap spending
measure and stayed focused on that and
talked about that for weeks leading up
to the deadline I think we could have
won but we couldn't get the votes for
that which was what was so frustrating
to me I spoke time and time again in
conference let's vot everybody knows one
really good issue beats 15 pretty good
issues every time pick that one good
issue and here's why it's so important
we come together because the country is
figuring out the crime problem the
Border problem Democrats have figured it
out so let's come together and focus on
that agenda as Republicans that's what I
hope we do over the next week and I hope
the speaker is the one who can lead on
those issues and the other things that
we told the American people we were
going to accomplish if they focus on the
two issues one we we have two trillion
more in debt this year because of
Biden's spending that's got to be that's
got to get under control the borders
have got to get under control those are
priorities that I believe you can bring
to the American people and you do not
need to compromise on last question uh
I've now heard from a number number of
people I know for a fact Donald Trump
has been contacted uh about possibly him
being an interim speaker is that a
reality I I don't know he'd be great but
I I actually I want Donald Trump to be
the next president United States if he
wants to be speaker
great I want him to be president R for
president he's still he's still going to
be running for
president that's where we need him is at
1600 Pennsylvania Avenue if he wants to
be speaker then that's fine too all
right well I think you do one the
temporarily to get you can't do them at
the same time you can't do them at the
same time I get
that you probably could all right thank
you Jim Jordan great to see you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else